what's up guys this is the 2022 Honda
Civic touring and for the 2022 model
year all Civics come standard with push
button start but what happens if your
key fob battery dies first let's just
remove the battery now of course to get
inside you'll need to take the actual
key out from the key fob but where's the
keyhole while it's hidden right here
behind the door handle now once you're
inside there's obviously no actual
Keyhole to put the physical key but
lucky for Honda owners there's a sensor
inside the key fob that doesn't require
batteries so you can still start your
Civic just put the key fob really close
to the engine start and stop button put
your foot on the brake and press start
[Music]
and there you go